hi everyone
um my name is Janet and I'm here with my
colleague Matthias Sokol we are both
with BCG gamma which is the data science
arm of the Boston Consulting Group and
today we'll give you
an open source Library we created for
Global model explanations
so um let's Dive Right In
yeah so um
yeah I mean explaining models is is
Central also to our work for many
reasons right I mean first of course to
make sure that models are built the
right way and they do they do what
they're supposed to do also using
Insight from Models to support business
decisions yeah often it's not enough to
predict we also need to understand why
and then what and sort of how to how to
optimize results then of course
explaining our models to the decision
makers who are often not data scientists
but they need to trust in the model and
what is it what it does and why and last
not least making sure models do not
validate ethical principles such as bias
for example
and of course explaining models has been
around all the time yeah
um starting with you know very simple
and tried approaches like just looking
at the coefficients of linear model
looking at feature importance I mean
it's something uh you know anyone almost
does by standard after after fitting a
model
um shap has been very popular
um in the past few years to um to look
at uh you know explaining individual
model predictions and um well with facet
we we add one new tool to that Arsenal
looking at how features interact with
each other right the statistical
dependencies between features how do
they complement each other or how do
they duplicate each other and that's
what facet is about and we can see that
in more detail on the next page
um so there's two things that facet
looks at for pairs or features right in
in the explanations that facet delivers
are always for
groups of two features
one is
to measure how much do does any pair of
features synergize which means one
feature makes the other Stronger Yeah
take an example in the healthcare
context that maybe you know age has to
be considered depending on the gender
right I don't know for example for you
know cardiovascular diseases that we say
Okay
um
um that that the interpretation of age
varies based on whether you're talking
about a man or a woman
um
and um
that also means I mean for the data
scientists of modeling removing one
feature
will not only sort of remove that
information from the model but it may
also reduce the impact of other features
that are in the model because they are
stronger interpreted in context
that's Synergy the other thing we
quantify is redundancy between two
features and that is how do two features
actually do the same for the outcome how
do they duplicate information
uh so for example again if you take a
healthcare example or health example
body mass index or waste to height ratio
are two ways to you know to quantify
let's say body shape right or or obesity
and that you can have play a role in
different diagnoses or predictions
um and um these two are different kpis
but they will be redundant because
um you know normally when you have a
high BMI you will also have a higher
waist to a ways to height ratio right so
there's redundancy
and that's really important because
um
redundancy brings many problems yeah for
example if you look at the importance of
features if two features in the model do
the same they have to share the credit
and their feature importance will look
less just because of the presence of the
second feature and I mean if you look in
the temp in the literature also for Shep
many problems with shap have been
pointed out in the past and a lot of
that has to do with redundancy so
understanding that in your model is very
important and you might say yeah of
course you know you can you can go in
and and for example calculate it Pearson
correlation but that only captures part
of the redundancy right that only
captures redundancy uh when the when
that's in a linear relationship between
features and the the approach we're
taking here is irrespective of the type
of relationship right it also works in
non-linear cases
okay let's head to the next page
um
so just very briefly because I mean so
how does facet work behind the scenes
there's also paper that you can find on
the on the GitHub repo a link to that
that explains more detail but just very
briefly
um Shep is uh is an approach that um
that explains individual model
predictions and it does so by giving you
a so-called shape value for every
feature
and the interpretation of that is that
um it tries to explain for every feature
sort of what contribution it makes to
the overall prediction
the total contribution of all features
is seen as the difference between the
mean prediction you know your
expectation
without knowing any information and the
actual prediction for a feature so if
you for example for for a model expect
to get on average if you average all the
possible predictions and you end up at
17 but for this individual data point
you get a prediction of 21 you want to
explain why is this Four Points about
above average and chap would tell you
well because of feature a being feature
you know having a certain value in in
this in this observation the prediction
would actually have gone down by 1.8
points and so on but feature D increases
the prediction by 3.7 and so on so
basically all the individual
explanations for the features add up to
the difference between the mean and the
actual prediction
and that means you get a sense of how do
the individual features contribute to
the overall outcome
next page please
now what what we do is because we want
to take a Global Perspective we
um when you have a data set basically we
take all of the observations we
calculate the sharp values for all of
them and then we form vectors
so for every feature
you get a vector of all the shape values
for the different observations right for
feature a you have if you have n
observations you have a vector of
magnitude of of size n
um PA then for feature B you have you
have a vector of the same size
and um
and the idea here the basic idea is that
now if we look at these two vectors and
the angle between these two vectors we
can we can see how much these two
features are working in tandem
so
um first of all the the magnitude of the
vector is a measure of feature
importance
if the two features are independent that
means that these two vectors are
orthogonal which means basically
just knowing the shape values of of
feature a you can't make any conclusions
about what you expect for the sharp
values of B because they do two
different things for the predictions
the more they are parallel or the
smaller the angle between the two the
more you can sort of derive the sharp
values from B for a which means that b
is very closely associated with um with
feature a
now there's there's more to that and um
uh and it I can't go too deep into the
explanations basically you get two
vectors one is for um what is the
general Vector of shape values and then
there's also interaction values and if
we go to the next page
and that's really just to give you a
sense of what happens what we do is we
take the shaft factor and the shap
interaction vector and we do a
orthogonal decomposition of these
vectors that allow us to quantify in
magnitude the synergistic parts of the
relationship of two features and the
Redundant part of between two features
and all sorts of how much of the two
features is independent so how much is
using is feature a using information
from feature B to get better
how much is duplicated between these two
features and how much is is really truly
independent contributions to the
prediction of both
if we go to the next page
yeah so I mean materials will go into
the details and then show a
demonstration of this how it looks in
practice because we think it's much
better just to see it with an example
but you'll see these visualizations in a
moment on the left hand side you see a a
matrix that we use both to show either
Synergy or redundancy where the same
features are on both axis of the Matrix
and as an added bonus the feature
importance is expressed as the size of
the rows or the columns so you can
immediately see which features are the
most important ones and in the fields
show you the degree of synergy of
redundancy between Pairs of features
the same data but visualized in a
similar in a Sim in a different way is
with the dendrograms that give you a
better breakdown of which features
actually belong together in clusters and
it's really just a hierarchical
clustering based on the um and using
Synergy in redundancy as distance
measures
okay
just one preview on the next page
another thing that we have Incorporated
in facet and that's also something that
we often use in com sort of as a second
step after looking into Synergy and
redundancy simulations
um I mean these are partial dependency
plots
um
but enriched with confidence bands so we
know okay how how certain can we be
about uh you know the the outcome of the
simulation
um we usually do these with features for
which we have confirmed that they have
no redundancies with other features so
we know that we're not constructing
infeasible scenarios and that we we are
sure that we can sort of freely modify
values of these features in the model
without having to worry about other
statistically dependent features and
we'll see an example of that as well
with that said I head over to you
matiosh
um for the demonstration of the library
sure thank you so I will change to the
move to the notebook
okay so in this short demo we will see
an exemplary workflow with faucet how to
perform a simulation how to analyze
these components of synergy and
redundancy to make some
um
some statements for a client so just to
introduce our faucet ecosystem is
compressed of faucet library that
contains core functionality that we've
shown and also circuit land BF which is
basically a library built on top of
scikit-learn to improve the software
engineering experience that will also
show you in this tutorial
so first let's introduce our business
problem so let's imagine that we've been
approached by a construction company so
it's a problem from civil engineering
domain they would like to improve their
products and one of them is concrete
which is basically a mixture of several
ingredients they utilize domain specific
knowledge what should be the proportions
of the compounds to make this concrete
as strong as possible but they're
curious if we can utilize data science
techniques to improve evidence even
further based on the data that we
collected throughout the years so for
this purpose we are using a data set
from UCI machine learning database
first we download the data set and load
it and here we see that the target
variable that we're interested in is
compressive strength
and the features that we're going to to
to use are basically amounts of the each
components like the amount of cement
water or super plasticizer So within
this mixture that's
creates then the concrete so we load it
then we do we don't need to do any
pre-processing for for this presentation
we just adjust
feature names to make them more concise
and we can move to building our pipeline
so we will use the Escalon DF as you can
see the plus the regressors that we're
using random first regressor and
gradient boosting regressor has this DF
at the end which means that for the
whole pipeline we will retain data frame
information like columns or indexes so
we won't end up with their numpy arrays
at any stage so this is one convenience
within this in this workflow and another
thing that we are interested at the
level of pipeline definition is
um
hyper parameter tuning so here we set up
distributions for each of the parameter
that we would like to tune and as you
can see we're using a parameter space
object that wraps our pipelines and we
set up site by distributions that will
be sampled here
so we built up our two two pipelines
that we would like to to utilize and now
we can move to one of the most important
classes within faucet which is a learner
selector
learner selector will perform training
suppress validation and evaluation of
the test set everything within a single
fit and here you can see that we are
passing the parameter spaces that we
defined what kind of search we would
like to perform so here we're using a
psychic learn randomized search and also
we Define a cross-validation approach
that we're using we perform a fitting
and after that we can access results via
summary report method
and basically here we can see the
ranking of all configurations and we see
that the gradient boosting regressor
with this specific parameterization
acquired best the best score of over 93
percent on Earth squared score which we
are content with so we would like to use
this specific this specific model we can
access this configuration with a best
estimator or attribute
and now we can move to actually this
inspector inspection one additional
comment here I mean we also built the
learner selector because we wanted to
create a simple means for our own use to
have multiple types of models compete
against each other so the choice of
model here is also parameter right so
whether it's random forest or gradient
boosting in this case
so now we move to the second
and most important class present in our
library so this one is a learner
inspector to which we pass this best
estimator and here we benefit the shop
calculation occurs and now we can start
inspecting our our ml model first what
we've got access to are shop values so
basically the sharp values of each
feature and here we can already see
what's going to be important for the
for later we see that super plasticizer
is below 0.1 where water is about
between 0.1 and 0.15 and that's going to
be important in the later part but
overall we that's all we'll see here now
we would like to actually inspect this
relationships and interactions between
features
so first that we are interested in is a
redundancy so let's move to redundancy
Matrix that we build and first that we
spot here is a high redundancy between
super plasticizer and water features
here you can see that they're marked
with
overall other values aren't really that
high and the other what was mentioned in
a presentation the width and height of
each column and row corresponds to a
specific sharp value so this is another
way of conveying a message how important
a feature is so for example you can see
that fly ash is so thin that no numbers
are displayed here so that's that's how
this additional information is presented
here
so moving from redundancy to the Synergy
part
here we can also spot some Synergy it's
these values are a little bit lower but
still we can see that for example super
plasticizer and fine agree aggregation
is 16 Which is higher than for water so
if we plan to get rid of that excessive
redundancy we need to decide whether to
drop super plasticizer of water or water
so that might be to drop a water as it
has for example a lower value for fine
aggregation that we going to retain
compared to the compared to the Super
plasticizer Fly action cars aggregation
are the least important so for example
we might consider dropping both of them
and this is basically the Synergy Matrix
visualization another
plot that we also seen in a presentation
was a dendrogram
so right now we can move to to it for a
redundancy
it's basically a combination of the
previous that we've seen But represented
as a as a tree here
So within the space we might for example
decide to drop fly ash and cars
aggregation and for example water to get
rid of this excessive redundancy that we
identified here so we can see that these
two features join pretty early which
corresponds to that redundancy that
we've seen before
and we would drop water here despite
when you could say water is more
important right it has a slightly higher
um importance here but we looked mostly
at the Synergy with other features in
their super plasticizer at the slight
Edge and I mean the expectation also is
that depending on how the model handles
two features it's kind of
random which feature gets used more so
um so in this case you know the choice
is for water
so now we re-run the whole Pipeline on a
reduced data set
so we defined which one which one are
redundant and are weak we say to drop
them and we rerun our pipeline
we again access summary report and we
see that we maintain the high score on
Earth square that we've seen before so
here we've gotten over 92 percent
and we rerun our learner inspector to
see how these visualizations changed
so first we can move to the shop values
and here now we see that super
plasticizer that before was below 0.1
now it's almost 0.2 so it almost doubled
which we might suppose it happened due
to dropping the water feature that it
showed a lot of
um redundancy
the another visualization that we repeat
is redundancy Matrix and here we see
that all values are basically close to
zero so we basically got rid of this
excessive redundancy
[Music]
again looking at the Synergy on the
other hand we managed to
preserve some of it for example for fine
aggregation we see with other features
that it it has this the present Synergy
values and basically that's something
that we paid attention to yeah maybe one
comment here you can see Synergy is not
symmetrical so the feature fine
aggregate gets a lot of help from other
features yeah we read this role wise we
read it across a fine aggregate gets
help from cement super plasticizer age
and so on
um but um
other features don't depend on fine
aggregate in return and that's that's
perfectly Fair because sometimes I mean
it means that that other features can
stand on their own but they give help to
other features just as well
so this concludes our part where we
inspected our model we built our
pipeline we perform training and testing
part now we would like to come up with a
story for our client to provide some
recommendation or or a statement how
they can actually improve the the
business problem that we that we
mentioned at the beginning and for that
purpose we're going to perform some
simulations so just to recap for a
simulation we select the feature so
first we're going to select Summit as
this was one of the most influential
ones we're going to create partitions
within each partition we will average we
will set the value to the average within
this partition
and then we will run the prediction on
this augmented data set then we should
see some Trend that should help us make
this make this statement or a
recommendation for our client so let's
run the simulation for cement and here
we basically get this plot that agrees
with with the domain knowledge that we
learned from a client so the more
segment we put into a mixture the
stronger it should get so it agrees with
what we learned and the recommendation
that we might give is that client could
increase cement amount to 350 and it
should ex they should expect an uplift
of about Five Points here compared to
the Baseline that was present in the
data set that they provided and another
important thing here is that we should
pay attention to the support below so
here you can see how many samples were
present in each partition and this is
important because sometimes there there
might be some unusual behaviors for
example at the ends like a huge jump or
a heat drop and this could be
potentially explained if there are only
a few samples there so this this is
important to interpret plot together
with a with a support below
yeah so the intuition of this chart is
you know basically looking back in the
past yeah and all the data points we
have we say what if we had always used
cement for example
um you know an amount of 400.0
how would this have changed the outcomes
the historical outcomes so compared to
the horizontal green line which is the
base I would say if we had consistently
kept cement at 400 we could have
expected on average
um an uptick of 12 points here
and the same goes well for 350 it would
have been an uptick of five so this also
allows us to have trade-off discussion
so there might be a component of cost
for example for a client or feasibility
saying well it's very hard to achieve
100 on a consistent basis and all of
that could go into discussion saying
well if we try to control this parameter
more and we we try to stay at least we
try to stay above 350 then there's
already some gain this is as one can be
seen here in the simulation
I just wanted to chime in and give you
guys about four and a half just a quick
one how to how to run and install this
yes so that's end of the of a
demonstration part let me go back
briefly to and we have lots of questions
whenever you are ready I will put those
on the screen for you
then in the meantime we put on the page
for um with a slide
yeah but that is self-explanatory
um yeah let's start so first okay so if
you want to install it here's the
instructions uh recommend to create a
proper environment because it depends on
some packages and you know standard
practice basically and there's
documentation 2.0 is not released yet
but there's a very stable release
candidate that we recommend you install
because it's got much improved
performance over 1.2
all right questions
thank you
so uh blue Tyson says how far have you
scaled this in practice
okay and scaling means in terms of
observations and in terms of features
right so um I mean the performance of
this depends mostly on on the
performance of
um on the number of variables you have
in practice we have applied this
approach with
um you know with with problems that had
over 6 000 or over six seven thousand
variables yeah in for example in
manufacturing in very complex setpoint
optimizations
um but what usually happens is that we
narrow it down to maybe 20 to 50
candidate variables and um and then
apply this explanation approach simply
because if you have more variables the
chances of having lots of irrelevant
variables is very high
um but it's absolutely practically
usable with I would say 50 to 100
variables it depends a bit on your
choice of model
foreign
I see a question here um there is a um
there's a paper
um you can find the link um on our um on
the GitHub repo now we point to it
yes we'll send it on us on this card
that's a very good question
uh Narendra
um right now we we weren't planning to
contribute
yeah
um
now I mean that what we have done so far
is that we we stay on top of uh new
releases of Shep and we uh we sort of
sort of uh compensate for changes in the
library internally so we have a wrapper
class around it
um what we are considering is to um to
implement our own vanilla shap explainer
for that reason right so that using the
shap library becomes optional
thank you
yep we will provide a material she will
provide it just right of
um of the notebook and we'll share it
afterwards yeah
very good
okay
okay yeah Matia same we will share a
gist of an old book and if you head over
to um to GitHub and the facet
documentation
um yeah especially using that link here
we're using the 2.0 document
documentation you will also find
additional example notebooks to look at
how that explains the approach in more
depth